بابا دي عملت داخل المؤسسه العسكريه
الايرانيه تزايد مع دخول الاحتجاجات شهرها
الثالث واستمرارها ليلا نهارا في كافه
المدن والمناطق الايرانيه قلق النظام
وخوفه من انشقاق عناصر الجيش والتحاقهم
بالاحتجاجات والمحتاجين كشفت عنهما ايران
انترناشونال في وثيقه حصلت عليها الوثيقه
اظهر الدعوه قائد كبير في الجيش الايراني
لتقديم تقارير يوميه عن اعتقال اي من قوات
الجيش او عائلاتهم خلال الاحتجاجات فضلا
عن الانتباه الى الاعمال التخريبيه ضد
المنشات العسكريه وتهديدي عناصر الجيش
المتعلقه بوجود عناصر الجيش الرسميين
والمكلفين وافراد اسرهم في اعمال الشغب
واعتقالهم من قبل الاجهزه الامنيه او
كتابه الشعارات المناهضه للنظام على جدران
الثقنات
يذكر انه منذ انطلاق الاحتجاجات يعقب مقتل
الفتاه مهتامين سبتمبر الماضي صدرت عده
دعوات تطالب بانضمام لعناصر الجيش
للاحتجاجات فيما يواصل قسم كبير من القوات
الامنيه وعناصر الحارس الثوري خاصه التصدي
بشكل عنيف للاحتجاجات ما ادى الى مقتل
المئات من المحتجين
ملوك الشيخ العربيه